[Musica]
buonasera a tutti io sono qui per
raccontarvi un po della mia vita perché
da qualche anno questa parte trascorre
scandita da volpi aquile falconi in
dimostrazioni di volo nelle rievocazioni
medievali e nel bar control quella vera
falconeria è una strada in salita e una
strada ricca di sacrifici ma anche di
soddisfazioni e di tante tante lezioni
da imparare
la prima che ho preso io è che c'è una
condizione senza la quale nulla è
possibile con un rapace ed è la fiducia
la sua fiducia nei miei confronti
se un falco non si fida di me non è
assolutamente disposto a collaborare con
me è il primo il primo rapace che
addestrato è un'aquila una fila delle
steppe maschio si chiama huracan ed è
arrivato proprio poco dopo che io avevo
cominciato questo nuovo percorso di vita
io non ricordo la prima volta che ho
chiamato huracan al pugno perchè per
tutto il suo primo anno di vita io l'ho
ottenuto sempre sul mio pugno sono stata
più con lui che con qualunque altra
persona però non dimenticherò mai mai
nella vita
il primo giorno del suolo libero era un
pulcino si può dire aveva tre mesi
quattro mesi era pennato pronto ma
ancora mi chiamava come se fossi il suo
genitore pigola va ogni volta che mi
vedeva quando ho visto che era pronto
che era in grado di spiccare il volo
l'ho portato a volare su una collina e
quel giorno si era il vento forte che
spettinata nei capelli ea lui le pen
ed è partito dal mio pugno e si è
appoggiato a terra ha scrutato per
alcuni istanti il paesaggio davanti a sé
poi aperto le ali e in quel momento lì
il vento lo ha reclamato
e lui è già alto sopra la mia testa che
continuava a pigolare a chiamarmi aveva
era sembrava che fosse così in bilico
dell'area poi io ho incitato da andare
lui ha preso a giocare con le correnti e
stato un momento unico e davvero
un'emozione grandissima
quando poi è stato il momento di
richiamarlo al pugno io ho visto questa
sagoma minuscola nel cielo diventare
sempre più grande e sempre più grande è
sempre più vicina alla fine con qualche
colpo d'ala era di nuovo sul mio pugno
questa è stata un'emozione immensa ma
solo una delle tante situazioni che mi
hanno fatto decidere che la vita che
voglio la vita del falconiere anche
andare a caccia all'estero e vedere
aquile reali astori gufi reali falconi
al massimo delle loro capacità vederli
fare quello per cui la natura li ha
pensati in realtà perché loro sono
predatori anche quello mi ha convinto io
non vi posso descrivere a parole la
bellezza la forza di una picchiata di un
falco pellegrino che rompe l'aria
davanti a voi però vi posso dire che
quando si assiste una situazione del
genere davvero si ha quasi la voglia di
urlare per la per la grandezza di quello
che si è visto
l'addestramento di questi rapaci si basa
sui loro istinti fondamentalmente io
faccio da terra quello che un genitore
farebbe dal cielo i falconi in
particolare hanno sviluppato il volo al
punto da essere esso stesso
considerabile un arma per cui io per
insegnargli a volare per insegnarli a
tirar fuori tutte le sue capacità di
predatore divoratore devo simulare una
situazione di caccia e per farlo
utilizzò un lavoro un lavoro non è altro
che una corda alla cui estremità è
legata alla sagoma di foglio che
riproduce un volatile oppure
due semplici ali essiccate io le faccio
roteare in aria
ero a teano e mentre ruote nel mio falck
e libero in volo e libero impara in
parabola re impara le picchiate impara a
fare le scivolate impara a fare le
virate impara a prendere le giuste
correnti per alzarsi e le giuste
correnti per prendere velocità è un po è
un po una danza dico danza perché
bisogna prendere il tempo il tempo del
falco con tutta l'adrenalina che ne
deriva perché credetemi che sono davvero
dei missili sprezzanti e l'adrenalina
anche quella anche quella mia legata a
quest'arte perché i rapaci non sono
animali da pet therapy non sono
affettuosi non cercano assolutamente di
compiacerci non gli interessa il
contatto fisico lo permettono
non è una cosa fondamentale per imparare
il rapporto con loro sono pure istinto
puro istinto anche dopo anni e anni di
nascita in allevamento e quindi un
falconiere cosa fa cosa faccio io
io tendo a non a domare non a inibire
questi istinto selvatiche ma io vado a
coltivarlo
vado a tirarlo fuori la soddisfazione
più grande per un falconiere cacciatore
è vedere che il suo falco non tanto fa
una cattura ma quanto che è competitivo
con un animale selvatico vuol dire aver
reso veramente onore all'animale che sia
e nel volo libero ovviamente dove non
c'è una presa la soddisfazione più
grande è vedere la capacità in volo
della propria aquila del proprio falcone
e poi il ritorno al pugno ritorno al
pugno momento magico perché perché non è
scontato assolutamente perché il momento
in cui un falco un'aquila lasciano il
pugno sono liberi sono liberi e ilor il
loro ritorno
dipende solo da come noi ci siamo posti
nei loro confronti
bisogna lavorare sul rapporto prima e
delle dimostrazioni di volo che io
faccio per lavoro una cosa che amo e
proprio mostrare alle persone non solo
il rapporto che si instaura tra falconi
real falco ma anche proprio cosa sono
questi rapaci perché spesso e volentieri
non c'è una cultura sul mondo naturale
dei rapaci le persone non sanno spesso
cos'è la differenza tra una civetta un
gufo ad esempio e c'è la possibilità di
spiegare o di farglielo vedere e io sono
convinta che il modo migliore per
spiegare e per far apprezzare e
rispettare queste creature in natura
anche sia proprio vederli in volo sia
mostrarli cose sono in grado di fare
vedere il mio falco che sfreccia logoro
ignorando tutto quello che è intorno
concentrato solo su di me è un'emozione
per me grandissima ma che mi piace
condividere con gli altri perché spesso
succede che le persone poi rimangono con
il naso in su a guardare nel cielo ea
domandarsi se vedono una sagoma passare
che cosa fosse così perché perché se
qualcosa lo si conosce lo si capisce e
se lo si capisce lo si rispetta io credo
che rispettare questi animali sia un po
come rispettare anche poi la natura per
questo che amo molto il mio lavoro è
anche se l'opinione pubblica spesso è
divisa nei confronti della falconeria io
ci tengo a dire che i rapaci che noi
addestriamo sono tutti d'allevamento
tutti e anzi che spesso e volentieri
allevatori e falconieri hanno
collaborato con enti per la
reintroduzione in natura di rapaci a
rischio di estinzione perché perché la
falconeria e una fonte infinita di
conoscenze su questi animali dato che è
una tradizione antichissima pensate
chiedo scusa
questo gesto che io faccio appartiene ad
una tradizione che ha circa 6.000 anni 6
mila e nel 2016 la falconeria italiana è
stata proclamata immateriale
dell'umanità per l'unesco stato un
grande riconoscimento
io da parte mia ho avuto la possibilità
anche di viaggiare in questi anni ho
conosciuto falconieri da tutto il mondo
da tutto il mondo sono state in spagna
sono state in austria
ho conosciuto falconieri kazaki è stata
sempre un'esperienza da cui ho imparato
tantissimo viaggiare confrontarmi con
dei metodi con delle tecniche di
addestramento diverse fonti di
tradizioni differenti sempre
appartenenti ovviamente al mondo della
falconeria
alcune di queste persone che mi hanno
spiegato i loro metodi hanno persino
scritto dei libri io sarò sempre grata a
queste persone a questi falconieri ma
non ho conosciuto solo falconieri
io ho conosciuto anche tantissime donne
falconiere tantissime perché la
falconeria a differenza dei arti antiche
che spesso sono state precluse alle
donne non è mai stata unicamente
maschile è pieno di affreschi arazzi
rappresentazioni antiche incisioni di
donne con il falco donne da me a cavallo
con il falco e quindi al giorno d'oggi
c'è una forte presenza femminile in
questo mondo sono donne direttrici di
centri rapaci allevatrici ver controller
cacciatrici siamo davvero in tutto il
mondo
adesso vi presento mi presento huracan
adesso al cappuccio vi spiego brevemente
perché questa non è una situazione per
lui consueta ci sono luci forti sono
telecamere c'è il tetto molto basso
quindi è una situazione in cui lui
potrebbe stressarsi il cappuccio è uno
strumento utilizzato in palco neri ha
molto comunemente ed è frutto di secoli
e secoli di studi proprio sui rapaci e
fatto in modo che le cuciture non credo
nessun disturbo al falco non stringe
rispetto all'ampiezza del becco non va a
toccare gli occhi è un semplice
strumento che gli impedisce di
stressarsi quindi è proprio per la sua
salute
ebbene con lui sul pugno
io vi saluto e vi auguro di volare imart
proprio come fanno le aquile anche
controcorrente perché perché un'aquila
sa che che sia un vento forte o che sia
una brezza
se vuole andare più in alto deve andarci
controcorrente e io vi auguro di seguire
i vostri sogni anche di cambiare strada
se necessario lasciando tutto quello che
facevate prima perché nella vita certe
volte fare un salto significa spiccare
il volo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]